great so computer check so next picture
is Sarah from the University College
London and calibra and UCL okay because
your for some of them are from
California doing your summer internship
with calibra that's why but none back at
yourself
thank you okay thank you okay so before
I start I'm gonna I'm just gonna give a
very quick introduction on proof of work
and this is just like to transition to
propose thing so yeah I mean proof of
work we have talked about it's not
already and it has many problems I'm
just gonna talk about a couple as I said
just to transition so one of the problem
is like probabilistic finally so as you
know in proof of work when we have a
chain you know we can never be sure that
it's like third chain because if we have
an adversary that has like enough power
they could just focus chain create an
alternative chain and so it's means that
usually in order to be sure that the
transaction is accepted we're gonna wait
for like some blocks some people suggest
you know six blocks but that's really at
the discretion of the users and so what
it means is that we have a high titans
latency so again that's something that I
think we have covered in the previous
talk and also before and the other
object problem with a proof-of-work
is the huge energy consumption so again
I think that's something we talked about
on Monday and I think that's kind of
like the obvious big problem with proof
of work we have you know climate change
a lot of us actually you know care about
the planets are really the there are
many reason why we would want to look
for an alternative ok so this was just
to to transition to proof of state so I
think most of the people probably here
you already know like the intuition
between prefer steak so let me let me
explain it here so in proof of steak
unlike proof of work we have an own
validator set so this are the stake
holder right they are the one that are
in charge of running the consensus
protocol so this could be like a
permission system for example Dalia
Monday talked about Libra where we have
you know a permission set of evaluators
that are running the consensus protocol
but you could also think about some more
like less more open or less permission
system where for example you could just
like people's it's some money into a
smart contract and so on something and
then this will just give us two lists of
validators right so this validator
during the consensus protocol so there
are many research a lot of research on
prefer steak and many different
protocols so for the sake of this talk
I'm gonna assume that the validators
they run a BFG like consensus protocol
so again we know they are there's one
person that is elected leader propose a
block other people you know vote on it
and that's that how it works and so what
is great with this is that we have no
Forks right because everyone has to
agree on them on the set so we have this
kind of like property of like instant
finality and not true for for where you
could always like have for now
additionally are usually this proof of
stake protocol there hello allow for the
set of validators to change right so you
could have you know somewhere here some
reconfiguration some people believe the
protocol and some people will join the
protocol and this will give us our new
validator right
okay so just so I've been you know quite
abstract here so just to give a example
of such protocol there it's like hot
stuff
there is also tender meat that are using
you know simmer stuff and similar
protocol and I'm sure there are others
so I'm not going to go into detail about
that okay so prove mistake it's great
now we don't have this whole proof up
for requesting energy we have instant
vanilla tea amazing but there are many
problem when we take when you take the
troop of water away there are many you
know vectors of attacks that have been
discussed in our community for example
you may have heard about nothing at
stake or grinding and today as suggested
by the title of my talk I'm gonna focus
on one specific attack that has been
discussed in the literature and it's
called long-range attacks
so for those of you who have who don't
know what they are I'm gonna explain
quickly so in their long-range attack we
have an adversary that somehow obtained
the cheese of past validators so we have
these validators they were in the
control protocol then they decided to
live they have no more stake in the
system so it could be very easy for an
adversary to just like bribe them into
selling their all cheese that they are
used to that they used to use for their
protocol because there is a second
nominee attached to it so so that's the
lacquer you know the main problem and
then if this happened then obviously
that's very problematic because an
adversary that has even the previous
keys that were used to run the protocol
it could just you know create an
alternative chain and it could do that
in no time
because we are doing proof of stake we
are not doing proof of work so you can
just trade block with lack to validate
your signatures so an adversary could
create a chain that is as long as the
owners chain or even longer so that is
very problematic because our users that
has that are using the system if they
just you know wake up and they see those
two chain they have no way to know which
one is the right one and which one is
the adversarial what ok so this is the
yes it's really not like before
sorry fake the most reasonable lock so
if I am just new judge just joining I
still choose the longest whatever in
change
the adversary can can can take the block
a pencil to some height of the honest
rain guys will not have the insanity
baby still have a stake in the system so
they mean it's have incentive to sell
yours yes but like the adversary we will
just not include it in its chain the
real configuration so there will be one
chain with like you know the new
validators that still have steak and
another chain you know maybe the
adversary faked some you know
reconfiguration but the idea is like
here it will still be the adversary you
know that will be the validators right
so yeah make sense
mm-hmm okay so so that's okay so yeah
we're saying that's the motivation but
but let me know if you that's the
motivation we are behind our work
winning couple is to give away for users
who have been online for some time and
you just wake up and see this to shine
they can decide which one is the right
one okay so the main idea idea behind at
work is to have our users Alice and Bob
so who are not the validators sign to
blows and so di years like if we do that
then the adversary that does do you know
long range attack it will create an
alternate an alternative chain but all
the users you know that we're online and
transacting like they will not sign the
adverts or check so for example someone
who wakes up will see always Alice and
Bob I have seen a sign this blood so
this is the adverse erotic so that's
basically the domain intuition between
this and so how does this happen
and this happens by having users
including in their transaction their
votes votes so now in a transaction just
as before we're gonna have a sender
receiver in the mount and the blood so
the idea is like it's not gonna be any
extra work for the users right they will
just like add you know hash in their
transaction we don't ask that they take
part in the proto in the you know
consensus protocol more more than that
okay now you may ask you know what the
you know
what's the motivation you know why are
we doing that you could also maybe argue
that's an adversary could also operate a
long-range attack on the users and
really like our main motivation for
doing that is that they are you know
many many users yeah to that very soon
but the idea is that we gonna wait the
vote so the signature of users by the
amount of coins that they have so an
adversary that just create like empty
icons and and and submit vote it's not
actually gonna count towards the weights
if you want them to change but that
means that the waiting is not going to
be dependent on the holding of the
tokens after you read and who actually
spends the transaction okay so I'm good
yeah that so that's why it's a bit
difficult to do that I'm gonna come to
that in in the next slide but yeah I'll
explain that that's indeed like one of
the difficulties that we had it's like
the money it's like changing head so how
do you weights votes I'm going to
explain that so just like quickly just
to you know explain like as I said the
motivation the motivation is that there
are a lot of users and they compared to
like the number of validators for
example blockchain and s3 on there's
like 1 billion public key yes really
concentrated the attacker wouldn't have
yeah yeah yeah that's a good one so
actually I didn't put it in my side
because I thought it'd look like more I
don't know visual but in our paper we
have like a graph of like how the
concentration of stake is distributed
and so basically so I don't remember
exactly but if I'm not right I think for
a cerium we had something like one-third
of the stake was concentrated between
like a bit less than 1000 public keys or
something like that so it's less than
like 1 billion but it's still like we're
we're more than for example the theorem
there's like what for miners
five miners you know same for for
Bitcoin
so yeah it's so in the paper that is
going to be online soon
we have a graph that and say the
thousand public keys might not be a
thousand and a thousand different places
or a thousand different people yeah I
mean like that's true it's like you know
concentration like we need to have some
kind of like this not realized like
concentration at stake but like to
practice like it's more decentralized
than than the like conscious protocol
which I've we've seen is like very
terrible like even here I have like one
hundred and thousand validators but
that's like an ideal number that we had
for prover stack like currently as I
said Bitcoin theorem is like four or
five validators which is kind of like
ridiculously small so the idea is you
have like another layer that makes this
attack harder right okay okay so now
that stuck I've explained the motivation
let's go to the core of the protocol and
so to go back to two years okay so just
to sum up so Winkle we have users that
include in their transaction votes for
blocks right and that's to authenticate
direction so before we have discounted
this BFG like protocol there is no fork
so for user that is online it's not like
they have to choose all wait who I'm
gonna vote for you know as long as
you're online you know what block to
vote for and so again I would true
answer I think was your question
it's Cohen's carries a vote and that's
how we're gonna wait to vote right
and also at the condition we asked you
note since these are the online users
that perform this mechanism so they have
to vote for the you know kind of like
latest blog or like the latest epic if
you consider on a podcast you know a
series of blood and that's again because
this users they are online
okay so let's me yes we have a multi
count and I want to sign in and give it
to you and you might want to sign it as
submitter in a year yes that's a problem
actually yeah we so the BFG chromium
kind of like abstracting your way so
it's based on proof of stake so we can
effect assume that there is some you
know working as I said it could be like
a permission things like Libra or other
proof of sec I'm kind of like not really
like oh so I mean the validators are
also users right they could be but the
users are not always validators is it's
only validators of the total yeah yeah
does not vote for my whatever
fakeblock's right so
so then in my new whatever fake you will
see after that do you have a lot of
votes were yeah yeah yeah definitely
so that's that's a coming in my side our
answer to that in a couple of sites okay
so yeah so first I'm just gonna
illustrate more this kind of equating of
of currents because I think that can be
a bit tricky and then I'll explain this
okay so yeah so let's say that we start
okay with one block where account a has
two kinds and a combi has one coins and
by default to assume that everyone votes
for the genetics plug because we assume
everyone knows about it okay now I can't
a sense according to see and vote for b1
right so the idea is that when a since
its kind the currents gonna carry its
votes so na the currents associated with
outcome C has a vote for b1 and so has
the current that is left in a account so
we have like two out of three votes for
b1 so that's how we do our country and
so then you know similarly if be
according to a and that vote for B -
that's current that has been son by B is
like painting by this vote so here we
have two current I'd wait for b1 and 142
you have a question no no yeah did the
list of validated of the specific number
of drugs
so sorry the list of elevators after
specific number of plots for example
after ten thousand of block each theater
should get a new list of what it is
wouldn't that solve this problem reveres
validators can not make the block is
supposed to mean so in our security
we'll assume that someone is like waking
up for a long period of time and so they
they didn't know if there was like a
reconfiguration of validators that's
that's the I mean what we are trying to
protect protect against ok ok so I think
so that's like the really like the main
intuition between how like the like
voting voting works so hopefully
hopefully that's clear it's clear enough
so as I said you kind of like have to be
like up-to-date so voice follow the
latest block or epoch and once there is
like you know two-thirds of votes for a
certain block then the block is like
checkpoint it and according to our
security assumption it means that there
cannot be another you know block that is
not consistent with this one that is
gonna be said pointing ok so that's so
that's what the protocol nah again I'm
gonna come back to your question and
kind of like try to look at what could
go wrong and indeed what could go wrong
is that our you know adversary is also
allowed to Owen cones and an X for
example you know just have a look at
this configuration just for the sake of
like illustration of the problem we
assume that Bob you know sends one going
to the adversary and the adversary sends
one's going to Alice so that's the
honest thing so you see in the owners
check if we allow allowed the adversary
to have one third of the money then here
the address allows one third he's your
tutorials one third of the coins no
problem but in the adversarial chain
that the adversary is going to do as
part of the low range
like the adversary could handpick what
transaction is gonna include so that's
what you are matching and especially in
that case the adversary should be like I
never you know sense Mike on to Alice in
the address Shane not the adversary has
two cars and if you have two kinds out
of three each chain fake a checkpoint so
so yeah that's why this is a kind of
like a tricky program because we have
this idea that the adversary can kind of
like choose what transaction to include
the knot and also this idea that money
is like by design changing hands like
all the time so more stake so that's uh
so that was like I would select the like
difficulty in doing such a skip okay so
now about the security why our screen is
secure so what we'll assume is that the
adversary has some fraction FY of the
total stake and now we additionally have
to add some other bounds about the
amount of money that is allowed to move
because if there is too much then that
opens you know the door to like attacks
and what we ask is like this to use F Y
and X they verified this inequality and
if we as long as we have that then the
adversary cannot obtain more than a
third of second it's going and then it
cannot basically Forge a checkpoint so
also you know I know we've been talking
a lot about like tunable security so I
hear I think here also as well you could
kind of like choose what your assumption
is depending on how much money you want
to give to the adversary or if you want
to have like a more flexible system
where you can exchange like more money
so so yeah that's also we discuss some
some bounds also in the paper but that's
basically flexible I the fraction of the
total stick or the fraction of the state
of moving
no of the total stage
okay okay so now I'm gonna talk about
Chi rotation so we also add in this game
a key rotation so this is to allow the
adversary to dynamically correct new
users so the idea is like some users can
decide you know at least to like change
her public key to be j12 from TK 1 to
potato and if she does so she has just
like she wouldn't know which ones
actually include a vote for a block
right and this low forward secret so
again I'm gonna quickly illustrate this
and like why we add a key rotation so
let's assume that in this state the
adversary you know has corrected Bob so
has access to the secretary associated
with speak everyone and later on we all
know the adversary to like change and
correct
Alice so na because at least she
rotation includes a commitment to Bob's
she rotation because it has you know a
vote for Block B 1 then if the adversary
wants to like huge Alice cryptic a 2 it
has to include the chi rotational TKD 1
to b kb 2 so it means that the adversary
cannot like simulates both keys does
that make sense
yeah ok cool
no ok so now i'm gonna do yes just
confused standard security right having
AI at most one third of them replicas
who can be manager at one third of the
nodes can be malicious that is what
windows security is right so because you
said FX play it is basically running a
PFG protocol that's so they are not so
the user so the validators are running a
BFG protocol but the users so the
adversary that has money and it's not
for example part of the Vator
they are not training a protocol they
are just
thing on the consensus protocol
underlying I mean bft is nothing special
apart from voting them any number of it
I can do one phase 2 phase 3 but
depending on that security protocol but
that is also just voting if I understand
and so how is this different I'm just
curious in that comes so the difference
is that in our case we have some like
some threat model where the adversary
has corrupted the BFG consoles protocol
by correcting the previous keys of the
validators so now like the adversary is
like really like is like faking a BFG
protocol on its own chain know is more
than one start so remember at the
beginning I was saying that past
validators that shoes to be validators
for the concerts protocol they left the
protocol right because they don't want
to stay forever and not they have no
more stake in the system so the
adversary can just be like hey I'll give
you 1 euro and you give me your secret
key and then the secret keys worth
nothing because they already you know
cash out and they are not part of the
system anymore so that's the threat
model that we have is like the adversary
compromise like the Past validators
because they have no more stake and
assisting make sense time is running
short but I'm still about curation okay
so in this block the adversary has
access to Judas secretly right which
everyone
and later the adversary crypt Alice
right so you could think that in the
adversarial chain the adversary and will
just omit the fact that Bob has you know
rotated its key and so the adversary has
two key Bob's and Alice right but
because we as we add key rotation at
least he rotation
it's like bounded to Bob's key rotation
so it means that if the adversary wants
to control Ali's accounts it has to
include Bob key rotation and yes
adversary does not have have access to
this
you make it harder because the investor
has to buy the entire history yeah
exactly yeah yeah exactly
so getting back so then the number of
total value dress in your system is
constant right total value details no no
no why I mean how much is the adversary'
number amount of address we can a system
have in your in term of State yeah sure
so remember my previous odd I was we
have some kind of like inequality which
is FY plus a fixture do yeah exactly
so that's in term of stake yeah the
running of the protocol
yes so that and that's basically that's
why we had a key rotation is like to to
say that you know at each period of time
the adversary you know has that mistake
and then if the adversary wants to like
change because of our tree rotation it
is able to do so but at each period of
time in the owners chain in the owners
chain at each block the adversary has at
most FY stage
so cringy turkeys when you do cute oh I
mean you come to teach yourself right
given a person so for example what
you're saying like the adversary could
have access to Turkey this key and then
fake a key rotation in its own chain
yeah it could do that yeah that's that's
possible yeah but then that doesn't like
that doesn't change anything the
adversary still has access to you know
Bob's account so yeah that doesn't
change anything it's the adversary does
that yeah is that does that answer your
question yeah okay there was other
question or should I go through yeah
fine okay so I think anyway it's free
almost done okay so yeah one more
problem that can arise now it's like
about meeting minting and block rewards
right because you know in a lot of
protocols like when you create a block
when you're participating the consensus
protocol you get rewarded and very often
new currents are created and so in this
case if the adversary has an adverse
solution they could just take all the
rewards to themselves and and very
easily they would be able to get you
know 2/3 of the money right so in order
to solve this problem what we asked is
that every mint transaction needs to be
checkpoint it before it takes effect so
it means that whenever there will be
like an intersection in the blood like
the transaction will the coins will be
created effectively for example I don't
know some blocks later when when the
transaction has been checked pointed
okay and by the way this is relating to
the stage bleeding attacks if some of
you are familiar with this okay so now
say I don't have much time I'll say very
quick word about efficiency and yeah we
are waiting for users to transact that
can be longer and we made some
experiments on Bitcoin and ethereum and
it is long yes it is very long between
50 days in a year you know in Bitcoin up
to three years you know one of the main
reason is
dislike Hodel movements so people really
don't transact a lot and and that's
that's a problem okay so one thing that
we discussed in the paper that probably
I will not have time to go into detail
is to add some kind of like delegation
scheme where users can delegate their
stake to like another user that is maybe
more active very quickly it may sound
weird because you know it's doing
delegation adds more centralization
which was kind of like exactly what we
are trying not to do if that makes sense
but in order to do that we want to you
know have some kind of like trade-off
between having you know a good
efficiency and not too much
decentralization so we use some economic
instances to obtain exactly Caples this
is based on a paper by last points and
his co-authors I think also buy CDs
mention in his in his thought reward
sharing schemes for stake post and so
that's to ensure that we have end of
decentralization so that it's hard for
an adversary you know to corrupt
everyone but still great efficiency and
indeed we kind of like simulated this
delegation on the ethereum and bitcoin
network and that is much much better
okay so now I'm actually done just to
say that in addition to what I've just
talked about you could also think about
adding some similar mechanism on a
proof-of-work because right now for
example Bitcoin has a centralized
checkpointing mechanism so if we want
you to make that decent realize we could
actually think about doing something
similar on on Bitcoin no okay okay so
yeah so that's how you would do it I'm
probably not going to go into the detail
and also the paper is going to be online
very soon if you don't have a look at it
and I don't know if you have time for
questions or no
is nowise we show that if you have a
chat finding and periodic social
consensus you can top the long range and
heart problems so how does play because
that is like a very simple solution and
people have done have to download the
software okay okay so it is there is
just no I'd also like decentralized and
but is it easy to validator that under
conscious protocol cuz - I am my
understanding that it was
okay but but then okay I'm not sure I
understand then how the adversary that
is creating the long range I take a note
that has two keys from the previous
validator so for me I mean funny it's
not here like who is doing this trick
pointing and how how an adversary that
has enough kiss cannot also fake this
but maybe you can explain to me because
yeah basically I mean for us like I
think there are lot of people that do
like checkpointing but in the kind of
like centralized way right okay okay
maybe you can explain to me later and
then I can yes kind of sanik able to get
this free validation by piggybacking on
these other signatures yeah but if there
would be a downside if it like breaks
lightning
so would it be if for example I don't
know there's like you can you can
include an older block with being your
transaction fee it's my error kit
multi-sig only one of the signers needs
to like melody so I think maybe this
could be solved but the delegation right
because I like even if you're you know
transacting with like you know some
wallet or using lightning or something
then and you know let's say you have
like another I don't know well you know
someone you know you have another
account that is kind of like transacting
like unchain maybe like less often or
something like that then you could just
like because I mean I think I think OSI
is because you do kind of like a lot of
transaction right so that's why you want
to go like option so like okay one you
know one way to dealing with that we
could be just like to delegate where is
another account that maybe you don't do
a lot of transaction so you don't
actually need the lightning and then
well so yeah it is the and that's what I
was saying so that's also we can of like
we're thinking of applying this like
incentive scheme to be sure that even if
we have some you know banks or pools
that comes you know just for convenience
and efficiency they are still enough
that we have more decentralization just
to have a trade off because otherwise
only cuz always one person is gonna
submit it so that person can always
my sunblock it's just signed off on the
transaction it might have been so long
time ago so I can't unless you worse
with your CD if you allow there to be
only one of n signers who actually okay
[Applause]